hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the new Slenderman shadow
map prison spending will decrease your
maximum speed over time and alert the
enemy of my position oh the enemy
haha I wonder who that could be anyway
welcome back to the newest slenderman's
shadow map that's been released prison
I've been told that this one is much
much much harder much harder so we'll
see about that
Harry Mille or Nellore Mille or mark
Stein ray purchase Morton ha Bert Nicola
Steven Anderson
I like it I like it loud what got I got
keychain light a little hand look at me
I'm all over the place
oh yeah ha ha ha Roy wider hell uh uh
invisible Florrie I've got a a pointer
thingy whoo ha ha ha yeah
all right I can dig it I like this am I
looking for pages I wasn't quite sure
flashlights it's looking good
all right so when do I ballistics nope
no glow sticks in this one I wasn't
paying attention him do get in aha
that looks like one page ha ha ha ha
photos all right then ah the old
familiar thumpety thump how I have
missed you over the years for weeks I
mean I just played Sunderman slender the
eight pages like this weekend so
apparently the guy Marx teen rewrote the
entire Slenderman AI in this one so oh
man this place is friggin huge or maybe
it's not I'm just kidding myself I don't
know I'm trying to get an idea of the
outline of the entire place first then I
will get along and doing whatever I need
to do oh you could go over here man this
place is huge it's so big all right
that's so long I know yeah where does
this go
I'm not going in circles here I'm not
even going in circles I'm just moving
forward
oh all right so this is a photo that
probably needs to be get got early on
i half-expected Slendy to be right
behind me there but I suppose he knew
better than to mess with me ha ha ha hey
what ha ha man that wasn't right sai-san
well lid oh hello
three three of eight not bad it's
awfully well lit in here ha never mind
no not I lied
oh god I gotta be like that
what ah ah we gotta move out okay let's
go around what are you doing you're in
my way I need to be Oh God haha Wow okay
so friendly this is a section that I
need to get like first or something I
don't know and the rest I just over here
oh come on it's like a huge big big
place what doc shot me I don't know
fancy symbols I don't even know where
the entrance is so if I get all eight
pages I won't even know where to go I
mean that's basically given I'm gonna
die okay I'm just I'm trying to get an
idea of how the outline of this place is
set up but it's gigantic and they're all
so it's a little icy ah click back on
light please oh no you didn't you didn't
oh you didn't I'll use out of a [ __ ]
can I have my light please climb I light
my light my light please Karami
all right oh no my key chains I don't
work oh ha ha it work ha ha Oh heads up
that's a bright keychain light like God
ha ha
what oh my holy crapola oh no what
happened there I shouldn't have turned
around that's for damn sure
bye bye maybe he's that good okay
hey did ya Harry Malloy I know it's not
my lure it's Mellor
Shan Quentin's and Jake Brooks Jake
pushes son guy he does a good job good
job
okay so this is the entrance all right
collect all eight photos you got it
buddy
whoever needs me to do that I don't know
oh man this is a whole other section of
the place guy I do not know the layout
just yet it's confusing as all get-out I
don't know where I am
I really don't hey let me go over here
because I want to get an idea of how
these cell blocks are set up because if
I can and that would probably give me a
better idea of how to navigate that
frickin place no all right
it's really quiet it's quiet without
that bumpity thump but I'm a rock I'm a
man and I won't be scared by nobody okay
I fully expected that to loop around
back again there's another cell aha
fellow click click click click click
ready click click click click click let
me quickly okay anyway let's just keep
going we're doing okay the thumpy thump
is back
we just carry on ah okay we're back here
somehow I see you dime you saw him he
was there
this is carry on I think there's one in
know there was one I thought there was
oh yeah there is there's there's there's
and there's one in the back yeah
definitely don't want to be caught
getting the last one back in this
alleyway over here he's gonna eat your
face alive wait no that didn't make any
sense he's gonna eat your face off while
you're alive yeah sounds all right yeah
good mark that's good yeah he's gonna be
right by me there's gonna be a fighter
I've got a very gruff ha all right man
oh if only we could have everybody but
really is I knows better than to mess
with me wait have I said
okay holy crap when the guy said he's
gonna make this one hard are you kidding
okay so whenever that little comes up I
should sprint cuz he's right behind me
ha ha ha there you go yeah yeah oh yeah
I were going to-- yes oh I'm a big baby
I get startled by little nervous I'm a
little jumpy guys don't make fun of me
I've also got the ball you've turned up
in my headset again so it may not seem
loud to you much love to me all right
take two or three yeah three so I'm
thinking that they're I don't know I
don't know how many cell blocks there
actually are it's hard to get my
bearings in this place okay this is the
big slob oxide by the biggest one all
the things there are walls it loopback
Pia passed it around that area
nothing here and then there's a whole
subsection over tastin and that wraps
around but for the most part there is
sort of a cell block type design
I think it's quiet again
I don't like it quiet alright so as the
first page I remember this oh he's quick
he moves oh man he is quick he's like
keep booking it huh that's not a good
thing not even a little bit I'm looking
back way too much maybe I should look
back I don't know the rules have the
rules of the game have changed I know
not of what I speak either way looking
back bad idea should do it shouldn't do
it who ever escaped from this prison
sure did a thorough job of making sure
that all of his friends could come with
him
okay okay this is aha
yeah this is back towards the beginning
the entrance so it's like two there's
two sides if you're playing in the
future and you want to know there's two
sides and then one side pass that area
that I've gone to twice now and I got
killed last time I don't know if I'm
headed towards that right now was that
him or it's like a u-shape I can't I
can't I'm not exactly 100% right now I'm
usually good with my sense of direction
but right now I'm more focused on not
dying okay okay sorry oh yeah and that
goes towards the interest so it's like a
hub and then though there's a u-shape of
a big central block area and then it's
just easy to get mixed up on in all
these backhauls and this is a ladder can
I get out please
oh I bet this is where I need to go to
escape oh boy okay keep that in mind I
know where it is in relation to the
entrance now you know like it is may not
like this
okay so it's dark down there is that
where the lightbulb went out before I
don't think this might be this might not
be a game that I fish on the first try
might not be ah how do Gaga wait why is
my screen going staticky when I'm
looking at you right that's why I
thought okay there's one in here I know
there is in the corner here so isolation
room OOP
I've almost got Oh
J unfriending I'm Frank this is back
where you get to the thingy to the thing
you need to the thingy look can I might
like please flip yep there we go haha
okay
so I'll get number three and number four
over in this area and they'll have a
pretty good idea of the layout Paul
Revere highlighted place kanagavel I'll
go you ah
hey I'm gonna give me I'm cute rifle
here I know you see none I know I know
that noise okay one more time what did I
do wrong there nothing I could do
oh man oh boy
use only when absolutely necessary oh
boy
it was hard really hard I mean I would
admit I took a lot of time trying to I
was walking a lot around the prison
trying to get an idea but I think that's
gonna fail this time
Thank You Harry Malloy I just want to go
like that once his name
Harry Melora
is it
okay no I'm not [ __ ] around so push
off we go
but delay photos see nope nope I still I
still don't know where all the locations
are I just have an idea of layout okay
nope nope photo there nope okay so let's
meander this way keep me
I shall find it here in another
isolation room oh I'm so smart and so
clever in my witticisms I will conquer
you Slenderman or I probably won't but I
believe in myself I'm so tough and brave
and handsome hmm okay where is that one
path go hang on I gotta check this I
have no idea where this oh I see him I
see him I gotta check down here because
I pass by this a couple times no no no
no no ah come on
never mind I was stupid I thought this
wou I like his new model I do got more
triangle shape of body you know
masculine Susans
and all that looks like you've been
working out trying to go from slender
man to buff man
yup man
I'm back here I'm doing not very good on
finding the locations of these photos I
mean they're all in the same spawns they
don't change dynamically but sailfin
found him I'm looking in the cells and I
just don't see him oh man I know he's
back there I know he wave was like this
oh no what there ah ah crap there's a
mistake I should miss bread Springs bad
okay ah come on okay
I have no idea what the layout of this
place is I get turned around so friggin
easily in those tunnels in there I have
to get like something written down I
don't know okay looks like this is back
to the other way place where I keep
dying my goodness
aha there was a page here the whole time
then that means there's three photos
just in this general area if that's the
case then the other ones pretty much add
up to eight then I dunno where all they
are okay I think I know I think I know
not gonna help me but I know at least
get away from me so I died
another ten ababa
say anybody go yo yo that's gonna happen
with these times ah oh I see your arm
hey buddy
what babe ah no I'm gonna get me a girl
get me not okay
you saw that you stare I can too or not
that's the opposite of what I want Oh
where'd it go
Oh where's it who's right here okay they
do change Oh crapola crap on us
Dec oh I'm so boned I'm so bummed I'm so
bummed I'm beyond boned
uh I can't sprint at all
I got like what two Sprint's is that all
I got then I'm dead I'm dead I'm a dead
man
I'm a dead man walking cuz I can't run
oh I don't even know maybe I do gotta
like spin around keep my eye on him when
he's behind me like that dark
give me my flashlight I'm pushing the
button
you're not pushy but no push the button
to push a wished button which button to
push
okay Oh God I think that he's like a
whole rethinking of the strategy in
terms of how to deal with the Slenderman
he wasn't kidding when he said he
rewrote everything so peeps gotta learn
how to deal with them now because it's
different the game has changed
Oh God so like seriously you got it
I think I think um this is just my
theory for all you who else are gonna
play it out there here's my theory all
right I think that you need to look at
him just long enough until you can get
him around the corner because if he's
got you on open ground like that you're
done cuz he's quick when you're not
looking he moves quick so you really
gotta take advantage of keeping your eye
on him before and getting around a
corner because man so if that like
happens that's why that's why when I
first died I was cranky knees crunching
this information my head was plain
that's why when I first died and I
turned around I saw him and I would have
been good if I'd have backed up and
looked at him but I turned and as soon
as I turned he closed that gap and got
me like that man
Oh guys I like his new model I do his
new mom's very good mark Steen you did a
good job everybody else on the team I
wish I memorize your name but mark Steen
just sticks out in my head you did a
great job in this new Slenderman shadow
map it really changes the dynamic of
everything in that that prison man I
don't know if that was intentional but
it it I'm good with directions but that
threw me I mean everything like look the
same and I got turned around so many
times so I'm gonna hit this again in the
future but for now I'm all at a time I'm
Way over time so thank you all so much
for watching hope you enjoyed as much as
I did click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I'll
see you in the next video
yeah